and Democrats wasted the last two years
of governing over fruitless obsessions
with the Muller report now winding down
and the Democrats stepping back from
their calls to impeach Trump was the
Democratic obsession over Trump in
Russia really worth it for their party
here with answers Glenn Greenwald
founder of the intercept Glenn it's
great to see you like you noticed that
hardly any of the Democratic
presidential candidates and the list is
growing seemingly by the day they even
mentioned Trump in Russia so is reality
finally sinking in for the Democrats or
some of these new polls about Muller
really what they're thinking about yeah
we actually saw this aura during the
2018 midterm where the victorious
Democratic candidates knowing their
local districts really well almost never
mentioned what the Democratic National
Committee and MSNBC excuse the
redundancy have spent the last two and a
half years obsessing on to the exclusion
of virtually everything else which is
not just the claim that Trump colluded
with Russia but that Russia actually
controls Donald Trump in some sort of
you know
klancy kind of espionage way as a result
of blackmail or other kinds of leverage
that disappeared from the winning
campaigns of 2018 because they know that
people don't wake up in the morning
worried about Putin and the 2020
candidates now see that the wheels are
falling off the cart of the Millar
investigation and barely mention it at
all in recognition of that fact and
Glenn Pelosi I noticed she was out there
today in Missouri and she was she was
backtracking a little bit on that big
bombshell admission last week on
President Trump and impeachment let's
watch and I said he's not worth it
it got your attention I've been saying
this for two years that he shouldn't be
impeached but when I said he's not worth
it then it got depressed and what he's
not worth is the financial stability of
America's working families and that's
what we're trying to correct
well do you believe her when the time
comes we'll see just think please think
about how stupid that is what she just
said
that the overriding theme of the
Democrats for two and a half years going
back to the 2016 election as I said
earlier is that Donald Trump is
blackmailed by or controlled by the
Kremlin and forced to do things against
the interest of his own country the
United States and in favor of this
foreign adversary now if that were true
at all
if Robert Muller had any evidence of
that it hasn't shown it to us he would
almost be guilty of treason and if Nancy
Pelosi really believes that Donald Trump
is serving the interest of Russia and
decides oh we're gonna just take our
time in removing him from control over
the nuclear arsenal and the executive
branch in the military until we feel
like we're ready to do it you would
wonder - just Putin have something on
Pelosi - why would you leave and place
somebody controlled by the Kremlin for
two years if you really believed it if
you really have it evidence for it and
of course they have none and they don't
have the integrity to just admit that
just two months ago she's on Twitter and
she's tweeting what does Putin have on
Trump and then I had the whole press
corps in the United States just forgets
that she said that just two months ago
yeah exactly I mean you know where I I
know you know we've been working on an
expose about some really incredibly
criminal acts on the part of the
Brazilian president I hear bull star
who's in Washington is this way yes he's
here meet with Donald Trump and there
yeah and and their use in and actually
he's gonna be on shannon bream show next
i believe there you see like what a real
scandal look like he's only been in
office for two months there's incredible
amounts of concrete tangible evidence
that has been publicly disclosed linking
him to the world's worst paramilitary
gangs and extrajudicial murderers in the
country that's what a real scandal looks
like instead in the u.s. we have two
years of speculation and conspiracy
theorizing and all kinds of espionage
fantasies that the democrats are now
realizing
is never gonna come to fruition Muller
has not indicted one American for the
crime of collaborating with the Russians
and people don't think he's going to
Klan also say Romans that time we there
may have been places in areas where we
could have worked with Russia even with
our disagreements about Crimea or
whatever but there there may have been
things that we could have worked on with
Russia that we couldn't do because of
Muller hanging over Trump I mean just
maybe this is the key that's the key
point The Bulletin of Atomic Scientists
says that one of the two greatest
threats that humanity faces is the
possibility of nuclear war between
Russia and the US Obama tried to work
with Putin now in Ukraine in the in Iran
in Syria Trump wanted to also and just
hasn't been able to because every time
he did they said AHA that's proof that
he's a Kremlin stooge Glenn thank you so
much and